هذه قصة رجل عالمي
في علم النبات ، رجل سافر عبر
كل قارة
إلى جانب القارة القطبية الجنوبية بحثًا عن
بذور ثمينة ومنتجات أجنبية ، تهرب من
السهام في جزر المشاجرة كاد
أن يسقط في جبال الأنديز
وتغلب على أمراض مميتة أيضًا  يمكن أن
تجلب عينات جديدة إلى الولايات المتحدة من A ،
هذه هي قصة ديفيد فيرتشايلد ، أنا
سارة بورنيت ، أنا نائب الرئيس
لسياسة العافية والغذاء في Panera Bread ،
لم يغير ديفيد فيرتشايلد
الطريقة التي يأكل بها الأمريكيون إلى الأبد فحسب ، بل
تعثر  بناءً على عامل الجذب الرئيسي
لأوعية حبوب الكينوا الجديدة ، لذا لمعرفة
المزيد عن فيرتشايلد
، سافرت إلى ميامي بفلوريدا وزرتها
فيما كان منزل ديفيد
فيرتشايلد مرحبًا ، أنا كريج موريل ، مدير
Kampong of the National Topical
Botanical Garden ، مرحبًا بك  إلى Dr.
فيرتشايلد غاردن ويل ولد ديفيد فيرتشايلد
في عام 1869 ولديه ولع حقيقي
بالطعام والسفر
والنباتات في سن 22 ، افتتح
مكتب إدخال البذور والنباتات في
واشنطن العاصمة وأصبح سريعًا
جامع النباتات الرئيسي لوزارة الولايات المتحدة  من
الزراعة لإخبارنا المزيد عن
مغامرات فيرتشايلد ، انتقلت إلى كبير
المستكشفين
تشاد هوسبي ، أنا زوج تشاد ، هذه هي
حديقة فيرتشايلد النباتية الاستوائية ،
نمت شجرة التين هذه من بذرة
جمعها ديفيد فيرييرو في الفلبين عام
1939 ، إنه لأمر مدهش أن الكمية التي وثقها
[موسيقى]
Fairchild StumbleUpon الكينوا في عام 1898 ، كان
النظام الغذائي للإنكا يدور حوله مرة واحدة ،
ولكن قبل أن يتمكن من تمرير عينة
إلى زملائه ، كاد فيرتشايلد أن يموت
عالياً في جبال الأنديز ، انزلق بغله
وفقد قدمه على قطعة من الجليد
على حافة  كانيون البغل ركله
واندفعه وأمسك فيرتشايلد بأي
طين أو جليد وجده حتى
لم يتبق شيء للاستيلاء عليه مثل ألف
قدم قطرة  eemed وشيكة رفع البغل
نفسه إلى Keen wild كان آمنًا
[موسيقى]
في عام 2005 كان يعتبر طعامًا
فائقًا وكان محبوبًا لأوعية الحبوب في جميع
أنحاء البلاد منذ ذلك الحين